Та ж може не фотографуйте, я хоч жетона вчеплю…
Нє, тута не приходиться нудьгувати.
З дня у день Петро Ольшевський патрулює
єдину в селі Птича святиню
Рішенням суду її опечатали
Тож дільничий наглядає, аби ніхто в церкву
не увірвався, порушуючи закон
Конфлікти були. Віряни, прибічники одного патріархату, хотіли зайти
а потім мінялись прибічники іншого патріархату
Ситуація, що склалася в Птичі, доволі дивна
єдина в селі церква вже роками стоїть під замком
а недільну службу правлять у церковній сторожці - українською
у гаражі - старослов’янською
Віряни Київського патріархату тепер сподіваються
що церковну суперечку вирішить томос
а православні Московського патріархату розраховують на суд
Я родилася в такій і хочу, щоб в такій щоб мене і поховали
Тутво даже всі є, тут можете не питатися
тут ніхто нікуди переходити не буде!
Ми з того й починали. Це нашою метою і було - об'єднатися
І щоб у нас була тільки українська церква
Зараз суди вже не потрібні по великому рахунку
бо є Вселенський Патріарх Варфоломій
буде Об’єднуючий собор,
ми будем УПЦ, вони будуть РПЦ
Значить, право власності належатиме вже нам.
Я так розумію
Цей вихід і президент так каже, і всі так кажуть
Конфлікт навколо храму виник на тлі подій на Донбасі у 2014-му році
Громада села захотіла молитися українською мовою
в УПЦ Київського Патріархату
провела голосування за згоди Московського патріархату
і більшість висловилася за перехід
Однак прихильники Московського патріархату після програшу у сто голосів
залишати святиню відмовилися
назвали голосування "незаконним"
і право на церкву почали відстоювати у суді
Ще у 90-х їм видали документ з правом власності на 25 соток
церковної ділянки з будиночком
Суперечки переросли у бійки.
Останні заворушення сталися навесні цього року
У сільській раді кажуть
залишилася остання судова інстанція -
касаційний суд
Однак тут справа припадає пилом уже майже рік
засідання ніяк не призначать
- Моя думка така, чекають томосу, така моя думка.
- У суді?
- Ну та, в державі, в суді.
Тим часом в УПЦ Московського Патріархату вважають себе потерпілою стороною
і мають намір позиватися навіть в Європейському суді
А про томос, кажуть, ще рано говорити.
Тільки Бог знає, що далі буде
Це рішення про томос
ми напевне не знаємо, чи він є,
чи він буде, чи його не буде
Ми спочатку подивимося,
як об'єднаються церкви в Україні
це ж одна з умов отримання томосу
наскільки я бачу, що вже УАПЦ з УПЦ КП щось там не можуть домовитися
а як буде далі, це одному Богу відомо
Не збирається відступати й громада УПЦ Київського Патріархату
Тут навіть провидіння побачили
Жіночки кажуть, ну я тоже так кажу
вона була у дуже такому вже стані
А зараз стала як нова. І ніякої реставрації, нічого
Є Бог на світі, значить, ми ідем правильним шляхом
Тим часом під церквою продовжує патрулювати поліція
щоб оперативно реагувати на будь-які спроби
незаконно захопити сторічну святиню
Кажуть, байдуже - київський патріархат чи московський
аби люди не бились.